guns are an inescapable part of video
games
in fact they feature promptly in movies
tv shows comic books and
pretty much every type of media going
no matter your stance them socially or
politically they can be a tool to
introduce action suspense
drama and intensity especially into a
video game
ever since 1992's wolfenstein 3d the
grandfather of the fps genre
developers have tried to create weapons
that balance realism satisfaction and
various other considerations
with what the technology at the time
could achieve now we all know how
frequent the site of a firearm is in
video games little
gun punfia there but how do they
actually work how do guns and bullet
physics change between games
how does the bullet go from here to here
the most common type of shooter
mechanics is hitscan this technique uses
technology similar to the one that first
allowed 3d games to be developed
raycasting raycasting was used to render
a three-dimensional scene into a
two-dimensional image
that could be displayed on your screen
rays would be traced from the virtual
eye of the player through each pixel in
the virtual space
calculating things like the color and
light of the object visible through it
to ensure it rendered correctly in the
game world the algorithm was made up of
a bunch of complex mathematics and
geometry but the calculations could be
done relatively quickly
which was perfect for first person
shooter games especially when resources
and computing power was fairly limited
take wolfenstein 3d for example it's
built from a square based grid with
walls being a uniform height
to render the world onto the screen a
ray is traced for each column of visible
pixels
the algorithm can then scale each object
to the correct size depending on how
long the ray takes to
intersect or hit each object
[Music]
scan weapons work in a very similar way
to raycasting and have done even as far
back as the previous example of
wolfenstein 3d
instead of a wide array originating from
the player's eye a more narrow one will
be cast from the barrel of a weapon
being fired
on the most basic level it will
determine where a weapon is being
pointed
use that information to generate a ray
and then using the same raycasting idea
of if a ray is intersecting with
something
to determine if that object is being hit
on a hit the game engine will then enact
the desired result
rendering damage in the environment or
to an enemy and initializing the correct
sound effects and logic
the cause and effect of the player
clicking their mouse or pulling a
trigger and the bullet hitting its
target all takes place instantly
and while that's obviously not how real
world weapons work game designers use
clever lighting graphics and
sounds to make the gunfire look and feel
as realistic and satisfying as possible
after game designers have nailed these
fundamentals they can go on to add
things like bullets ricocheting by
programming rays to bounce off surfaces
or adding bullet penetration by allowing
the ray to continue traveling through
each target
up to a set distance another method to
mimic realism was to add variables to
the angle or placement of the ray
which would give a sense of bullet
spread from wolfenstein 3d
doom and goldeneye to more modern games
like call of duty overwatch and
counter-strike
most weapons in fps games use this
method of implementing their gunfire
hit scan games tend to be a little more
accessible as you're not asking someone
who just picks up a game to start
learning things like
bullet drop or lead times the learning
curve is a little more shallow but it
does mean you get instant gratification
from utilizing your virtual armory but
there's also another method that's a
little more grounded in realism
that many shooters use to create a more
immersive experience
games that want their simulated weapons
to be as close as possible to the real
world counterparts
are more likely to implement a physical
projectile system rather than computing
shots fired with a detecting
intersecting rays a new object is
spawned with each round fired from the
weapon
as the bullets exist as a real entity in
the game world it means that they can
have their own values and behavior
each shot has its own mass and velocity
with the potential of in-game systems
influencing each individual bullet
things like gravity and wind can start
to affect the flight path of your lethal
payload with this system
but it comes at the cost of requiring
extra computing power
since each object will have its own
behavior and logic applied to it
the game engine as well as the game
client and any multiplayer servers
must make use of both raw computing
speed and clever workarounds
to ensure the game experience remains
consistent between each player
games that use this method will tend to
have a slightly steeper learning curve
and a higher skill ceiling
because obviously they need to take into
consideration things like bullet drop
and lead time
of course depending on how far they
choose to engage two of the most popular
titles that predominantly use physical
instances of bullets are pubg
and the battlefield series games that
boast a more realistic combat experience
and two franchises that i personally
really enjoy but even i can admit they
aren't the easiest to get
into for first-time players but game
designers don't have to stick with one
technique or the other
in fact it's pretty commonplace to have
both techniques merged together into the
same game
take fortnite for example for the most
part the weapons are hitscan which lends
itself to the faster
paced close combat gameplay experience
but then their sniper rifles use a
physical projectile system
players that take the time to consider
bullet drop and compensate for a moving
target
are rewarded with a high damage attack
from a potentially safe range
it's also extremely common to see games
that have weapons like rocket launchers
and bows
use a physics system for those while the
rest of the arsenal will be hit scanned
overwatch is another example of this
combined system soldier 76 in particular
his assault rifle is hit scan but then
the helix rocket he can also fire is
physical but the mechanic a developer
chooses will depend on its audience
the genre of its game and the technical
restrictions it's under
but what's most interesting is that
while shooters look and play so vastly
different from those from the ps1
n64 and even ms-dos they still have very
similar central mechanics and ideas at
their core
these are mechanics that have been
refined and improved over time of course
but fundamentally
they are still very much grounded in the
first iterations of these ideas
but i suppose you know what they say if
aim broke don't fix it
[Music]
but for now at least you should have a
better understanding on how the enemy
team keeps mowing you down
but would you prefer the instant
gratification of hitscan or taking the
time to learn the physics system of a
ballistic based fps
let me know in the comments section
below or you can find me on twitter at
irregular dave
and until next time thank you so much
for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you